the u.s senate has voted unanimously to
make
juneteenth a holiday that until a few
years ago
very few people had ever heard of into
a national holiday and when the senate
votes unanimously for something
you can be almost certain that it is a
bad idea
the juneteenth holiday may not put an
end to racism
but it sure will get you accused of
racism if you don't celebrate
this recently popularized feast but i
don't really care
what the libs call me so we will get
into it then
chuck schumer calls kids [ __ ] joe
biden calls mom's birthing people
and even fire brand congressman marjorie
taylor greene apologizes for something
that she said
get in control of the new language
before it leaves you
speechless i'm michael noel's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from auto pump fraud
okay who writes quote if slavery was
america's original
sin and we abolished slavery more than
150 years ago
i guess that means our nation is now
sinless and is such perfect
what does the left have to complain
about you know this is an interesting
point
because it shows the problem of the
slavery as original sin issue
which is in real original sin we're
talking about the sin of adam
that causes sin and death to pervade the
world
mankind has fallen were imperfect and
were
were up the creek without a paddle then
at the incarnation
and the crucifixion and then the
resurrection christ
defeats death on the cross and redeems
mankind
however the temporal effects of sin
are still in the world so christ
has this perfect sacrifice of himself on
the cross redeems mankind
opens up eternal life to us but we're
still in a fallen world because the
temporal effects of sin remain
so the issue with the slavery is
america's original sin
issue here is one it's it's just not
true because original sin is america's
original sin but also
you've got the original sin then you've
got this sort of
salvation by works idea that you know
there's the
the civil war that's going to free the
slaves and then
we're going to save ourselves but we
obviously don't because what the left
would argue is
the temporal effects of that sin through
racism still exist
and the problem for that ideology is
there ain't no redeemer so we're always
cut
in that mire of sin what a heavy way to
start today you know
i guess i i have all this energy because
of how
great i sleep on my helix helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else doesn't make sense you're a
very special person okay
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you
sleep they have several different
mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers head on over to helixsleep.com
knowles it's very very simple you take
the two minute sleep quiz they'll match
you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life and it'll ship to your door
for free i love i love my helix
mattress they got a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but
it it's a meaningless promise because
you're totally going to love it there's
going to be no need
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders right now and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash knowles
helix sleep.com and also up to 200 off
and two free pillows
speaking of absolutely sacred
things we we can now
add another festival to the secular
liturgical calendar
juneteenth a national holiday
you know i asked this question i knew
what it would elicit
but i asked the question on twitter i
said what was accomplished
by making juneteenth the national
holiday and all these blue check libs
who are journalists or politicians or
whoever
write into me they say you're a racist
you how dare you ask that question your
could
your clan hood is showing you you how
dare you
how dare you suggest that juneteenth
the most holy day of the year should not
be a national holiday and i
i i looked at just one of these guys i
just picked one of them at random
and i said you know i bet that this
person
never had anything to say about
juneteenth until
at the very most a few years ago so i
took his i don't even remember his name
but i took his name it was some journal
blue check
typed it into google typed in the word
juneteenth and i set the custom search
range
from 1970 until 2018 do you know how
many results came up
zero nobody knew about this thing
outside a few people
in the regional areas where juneteenth
was even recognized
nobody had heard about this thing until
a few years ago
now we are all supposed to pretend that
we've all known about it forever
especially the libs pretend that they've
known about this for years and years and
that this is a very important holy day
in america
i think it was a bad idea to make
juneteenth national holiday i know this
is an unpopular opinion
and more people are going to call me a
terrible racist bigot whatever person
i don't think the point was to
have everybody celebrate the the wonders
of
abraham lincoln and the union troops and
america
and the promise of this wonderful
country and i don't think the point was
to express
gratitude for our country or to
celebrate much of anything
i think the point was to just
pick a scab more and more and more to
say that america is essentially a racist
awful place
when i asked what is accomplished by the
juneteenth holiday
a lot of people ask well michael what's
accomplished by any holiday what was
accomplished by
the creation of columbus day and there's
a very specific answer
one the broad answer is columbus day was
in part designed to recognize one of
history's greatest men
christopher columbus who discovered the
new world but the very specific
political reason why columbus day was
created is to make italian americans
feel more welcome in this country
one year after they were the victims of
the largest mass lynching in american
history
there was a mass lynching the largest
one ever in 1891
in louisiana it was 11 italian guys
the history doesn't teach this very much
but it's true 1892
on the 400th anniversary of columbus's
voyage you get the first
uh columbus day at the national level
this was a one-time holiday
comes back a little later on okay fair
enough
what is accomplished by juneteenth well
what they're going to tell you is it's
to celebrate the end of slavery what you
racist
you don't want to celebrate the end of
slavery juneteenth does not mark the end
of slavery
it doesn't there are a few dates that
you could say mark the end of slavery
you could how about the emancipation
proclamation why don't we have
emancipation proclamation day
why don't we have 13th amendment day
that actually ended slavery
why juneteenth the day that word came
from certain troops to texas that
slavery was going to be abolished i
think there's a specific answer
if it's emancipation proclamation day
then you've got to give credit to
abraham lincoln but that is
very contrary to the new leftist
ideology which says
that we should not give white men any
credit for doing anything right
actually there was just an article the
other day by a cultural critic against
tom hanks we read it on this show
where he said the problem with tom hanks
is he's played
in his historical movies white men who
do the right thing and we shouldn't
acknowledge that
when the lincoln movie with daniel
day-lewis came out some years ago
one of the big criticisms from the left
is that it gave too much credit to
lincoln for freeing the slaves
the slaves freed themselves darn it i
mean that isn't true
abraham lincoln freed the slaves but
you're not allowed to give credit to the
white savior who who did this you're not
allowed to give credit to the
overwhelmingly white
union soldiers in the civil war not
allowed to give credit
to the white legislators who who
ratified the 13th amendment
so i think that is part of the reason
we'd have to have something nice to say
about some of the statesmen in our
country
who cares the left always says oh who
cares
come on come on what you're going to
complain about a holiday i had one of
these other blue checks yell this at me
what you're going to complain oh gosh
okay yeah that's a winning strategy
you're going to complain about a holiday
that
recognizes who cares man
the left cares have you ever noticed
that whenever conservatives call out
the libs on their cultural
ploys the libs always say oh who cares
it's not a big deal
come on who cares if we let husky hank
go into the women's bathroom because
he's got a wig on oh it's not a big deal
who cares if little girls have to change
in front of boys at the public swimming
pool
it's not it's just not a big deal oh who
cares
that we're killing a million babies a
year through abortion do you really
think it's really this is the hill to
die on really
that who cares about critical race
theory uh you're gonna get all wound up
about
some educational theory in schools come
on who cares about a new holiday who
cares about pride month who cares about
this who cares about that
the left cares that they are the
aggressors in the culture war by
definition
you've got the culture and then when
radical changes are made to the culture
it ain't being made by conservatives
it's being made by
the radicals why do they care so much
why do they invest so much time and
money
in the pronouns and the holidays and the
educational theories and why do they
invest all their resources in it because
they know
that the cultural issues matter
tremendously far more than any stupid
tax cut
that republicans seem solely capable
of focusing on at any given time
the the point of the juneteenth holiday
i suspect is to cast
more light they will say on america's
awful terrible racist past
to emphasize to an absurd degree
the existence of slavery in america
something not unique to america not even
particularly
egregious relative to other nations even
in the americas
in america right think about the number
of african slaves imported to places
like brazil
totally dwarfs the number of african
slaves in america think about the period
of time
in which the united states and the west
more broadly
tolerated slavery very small period of
time
relative to the history of slavery in
other places like africa sub-saharan
africa north africa
and the far east where it still exists
today but no this is america's sin we're
gonna have
i'm shocked we don't have five more
holidays pointing out
the awful original sin of slavery from
which there is no redemption
and republicans go along with it
republicans go along with it to prove
that we're not racist
to people who don't care that you're not
racist to prove
that actually yes it is america's
original sin you hear
you hear republicans say this so it's a
losing
losing strategy folks you're not going
to beat the left at their own
game now some some politicians are
pushing back on this
this kind of crazy narrative you're
seeing it at the state level right now
which is where they have a lot more
freedom to do it you're seeing it in
various states that are banning critical
race theory
most notably in florida with ron
desantis
ron desantis is a booting critical race
theory from the classroom
his opponent the agricultural
commissioner the democrat nikki freed
who's running against him for governor
has come out and said that this governor
is trying to create not just another
culture war
but another race war this is another
opportunity for
the governor to create a race war in a
cultural war
inside of our state i want everybody to
rest assured
first of all critical race theory isn't
the new boogeyman
of the republican party it's not
something that's taught
in the state of florida but we need to
let our teachers do their jobs and
that's
teach and this is again this governor
and this board of education who again is
appointed uh solely by republican
governors both by ron desantis and the
previous governor as well
and it is not their job to tell our
teachers
you know how to you know sure there's
parameters of aware
policies but this is a time when they
have overstepped
once again government and stepping in um
the job of educating and and not the
teachers
excuse me government is stepping into
the job they're overstepping
by having something to say over the
government schools are you what are you
talking about
you have schools run by and funded by
the government but you're saying the
government doesn't have any right to
make the curricula
by definition the government has to make
the curricula and hopefully this
the parents and hopefully the local
governments the boards of education
but what are we saying now the teachers
have the right to teach anything they
want you don't believe that if a teacher
went in there and taught that donald
trump's the greatest president in u.s
history you'd be calling for that
person's head on a pike
critical race theory is not being taught
in florida yes it is it's not they're
calling it a boogeyman here you go you
can read all about critical race theory
it's a
now probably a 25 or 30 year old
academic movement it's
it's derived from critical theory which
is a broader academic movement which you
can read more about
actually coincidental or providential
timing in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling months i
couldn't leave the bell my guys have
been a little slow on the bell i had
i had to get my own bill just in case go
get the book
this is such a disingenuous argument
from nicki freed
and desantis not backing down
very important to go out do things for
yourself you understand
if you want to do things for yourself
you want to get some good parts at a
good price for your car
you got to check out rock auto it's
wednesday morning
and you you've got it you're going to
check the the auto parts website to see
if now
is going to be the gimmicky 20 off or
maybe no is that going to be thursday
night i forget well don't don't worry
about that ridiculous stuff
rockauto.com always has reliably low
prices you don't need the gimmicks
you don't need to go well is it is now
the time and i got to pretend that i'm a
professional because the professionals
get a special price
but to do it you're saying no it's the
same prices for pros it's the same price
for do-it-yourselfers well you probably
need a special
no it's just very simple catalog all the
parts
for your car truck that you're ever
going to need reliably low prices
all the time same prices for the pros
and for do-it-yourselfers
just you don't need to think about it
and you certainly don't need to go into
that brick-and-mortar where they're
going to
ask you a thousand questions and they're
not going to have the part that you need
and they're going to go online and
they're going to go to rockauto.com and
they're going to charge you twice as
much
don't do it make it simple rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck then write knowles
knwles
and there how did you hear about xbox so
they know that we sent you
the democratic challenger to ron
desantis for governor in
in 2022 this woman nicki freed
has been making demonstrably false
claims
but it's going to show you the strategy
of the left on specifically this issue
of critical race theory
critical race theory is is a fairly
well-defined academic movement you got
big people who have contributed to it
kimberly crenshaw is the most most
famous one
uh but plenty of pseudo-academics here
there's a forward by cornell west who is
a well-known
academic huckster in the in the academy
uh sometimes he says interesting things
but a lot of what he says is is
pretty kooky this exists
it does not only exist in as much as you
go into your classroom and the teacher
says okay students
put away your math textbooks today we're
going to study critical race theory
critical race theory like all of these
critical analyses
are academic lenses that pervade
all sorts of different departments right
we've seen some examples of what is
taught by critical race theory the idea
that white people are all racist
the idea that objective truth just does
not really exist the idea that your
faculties of reason are unreliable
the idea that many things that come out
of the crazy academic movements of the
20th century
the idea that we we
are subconsciously so vicious and racist
that that the whole country is
is defined by systems of oppression
that work in an intersectional way a
friend of mine the other night asked
michael what is intersectionality and
a lot of people that's one of these
stupid terms that basically means
here's an example i'll describe it by
way of example
if you're a black guy you're oppressed
if you're a woman
you're oppressed but if you're a black
woman
oh you're super duper oppressed more so
than those other two categories
but if you're a black woman
who is a lesbian you are going to be
more oppressed than either the black
woman or the lesbian so now you've got
another layer down
but if you are a black woman who is a
lesbian
who is disabled who is missing an arm or
something you are going to be more
oppressed
than just the black woman or the
disabled person and do you see the
problem here with this hierarchy of
victimhood and grievance
there's no end to it even if you can
reach
some kind of physical end do you know
what's going to happen
they're just going to invent new
categories of victimhood this is
a lot of what you're seeing going on
with the with the gender craziness every
three days they seem to invent a new
gender
so we went from two genders to three
genders to five genders to 56 genders to
now it's something like 70 genders
why because they're always there's a an
incentive for greater grievance
there is a social currency to victimhood
and
there is uh no end to the the depths
that one can plumb when they're looking
only at themselves
and that and truly the depths you know
the depths down
down and down and darker and darker and
so you you end up with this crazy
crazy system that that has no end to it
that is being taught not just in schools
it's being taught in corporate
boardrooms it's being taught in our
institutions
it's being taught the military for
goodness sakes is right to boot that
from the schools
and i hope desantis stand strong even as
people
look if you criticize this stuff at all
the whole reason they focus on
these racial issues the dividing line in
america and they're focusing on from crt
to juneteenth is because they know that
if you ever speak out against them in
any way
they can smear you as a racist and it
doesn't matter if it's not true
they're just gonna do it and hopefully
desantis can stand up to that sort of
thing
usually democrats are very good at uh
controlling the language controlling uh
words and controlling minds something
you can read about in my opinion
speechless
oh man this is by the end of the week
it's just gonna have a gong i think by
the end of the week
because there's only there's only what
five days left to pre-order the book and
get a signed first edition copy of
premier collectibles
sometimes democrats make
the mistake of not keeping up with the
new jargon
chuck schumer you know he's not not a
spring chicken exactly he's been around
a long time
chuck schumer was recently giving an
interview he made a
terrible mistake of using language that
was perfectly acceptable not that long
ago but currently
is totally unacceptable this initiative
actually will house the homeless
population that is actually living on
our streets we see them every day yes
you're about to house them and they're
against it it's it it's unbelievable
yeah i mean it's i i have found that my
whole career
i wanted to build uh in when i first was
assemblymen
they wanted to build a congregate living
place for [ __ ] children
the old neighborhood was against it
these are harmless kids they just needed
some help
we got it done chuck schumer had the
audacity to call [ __ ] children
[ __ ] children you can't you're not
allowed to say that
what are you supposed to say now i don't
know i don't know because it's a
it's a euphemism right they're all all
sorts of euphemisms the word [ __ ] is
itself a euphemism
it just means slow there's nothing
intrinsically offensive about that
other than it's it's describing
a handicap and so because it is
undesirable to have a handicap
the the euphemism sounds undesirable and
so people take offense at that
but what is he supposed to call i mean
the word [ __ ] itself was a
replacement for older
words that were then considered more
offensive now what are we supposed to
say mentally challenged mentally
handicapped one of the
new euphemisms is handicapable worth
pointing out because
there are two different kinds of
euphemism all of us use euphemisms to
soften
harsh language so we refer to a woman of
a certain age
instead of an old hag you know the old
hag
is a woman of a certain age we say of a
certain age because it's a little softer
but it doesn't
negate the reality we're describing
[ __ ] or mentally challenged or
simple or whatever doesn't
negate the reality that we're describing
but the politically correct
style euphemisms where you go from
handicapped to handicapable
as though you have sort of extra powers
that does negate
the reality that you're describing that
that is so often what happens
with the way that pc works but
there are more euphemisms chuck schumer
fell afoul of the
of the current popular one but
let's move over to the the people
who give birth to all sorts of children
we used to call them mothers used to
call them moms
now not so much in the in the
biden budget mothers have been replaced
by the term
birthing people senator lankford
recently asked
xavier becerra the head of hhs
to help him out to figure out that the
definition of this strange new term
i also noticed you changed a term in
your budget work
uh you shifted from in places from using
the term mother to birthing people
rather than mother can you help me get a
good definition of birthing people
well i'll i'll check on the language
there but i think if we're talking about
those who give birth
i think we're talking about uh i i don't
know how else to explain it to you then
but
it i was a little taken back when i just
read it and saw it that it's
that the term mother was gone in spots
and it was replaced with birthing people
would you at least admit calling a mom a
birthing person
could be offensive to some moms uh that
they don't want to get like a happy
birthing person
card in may or i mean can you at least
admit that
that term itself could be offensive to
some moms
senator i'll go back and take a look at
the the terminology that was used and i
could get back to you but
again if we're trying to be precise in
the language that's used
mom's a pretty good word that's that's
worked for a while and i think that's
pretty precise
we're trying to be precise in the
language that's used you're trying to be
precise
well if you want to be precise you you
would say mother
that's the most precise it's the most
concise way
to describe it but we can't and we are
told
that now the simplest the simplest way
to understand mothers is as birthing
people
we are told that this is a more neutral
way a less offensive way to say because
the theory is
that some men can give birth because the
theory is that some women
can magically become men by wishing and
so because the theory is that our human
person has nothing to do with our bodies
because the theory
is the now popular adoption of the
radical transgender theory which is
a ridiculous ancient heresy
that is not a neutral playing ground
that really matters the
the semantic shift from mother to
birthing person
carries with it whole premises it
carries with it a whole culture
and what xavier becare is trying to say
here's oh you know senator i don't know
i mean i'll go back to the language i
just think come on it's not
it's not a big deal come on it's not a
big deal just
it's we're being precise okay just come
on just
uh and did you hear he he hesitated he
said look i think when we're re
excuse me mr bisera are you referring to
mothers here well look i think it's
pretty obvious when we're referring to
birthing people people who give birth
we're referring to
and then he stops himself because he he
he can't say mother
because if he says mother he's admitting
that of course that is the more precise
and concise and direct way to say it
but he can't grant that because he is
beholden to the radical
view that men can give birth
that's what oh come on who cares who
cares you care buddy you're doing a
whole big dance around to avoid
the plainest simplest most accurate word
you can possibly use why
because of the radical culture
anti-culture that you are bringing
with you xavier becerra
gosh the one thing that could maybe make
him a
you know a little more likable as if the
guy had a beard
but he doesn't he doesn't even have a
beard go check out beard supply people
ask me all the time michael
michael how can i be more manly i say
look there are different ways to do it
you can you can wear collared shirts
with uh
crew neck sweaters over them you can
play the ukulele you can smoke cigars
you can do
look obviously people want to ask me all
about this if you're not capable of that
sort of stuff
the next best thing you can do have a
really cool beard
you know it's real who's asking it's
matt matt matt is the one who asks me
about this stuff
and he's got he's got a nice beard you
know okay it's a nice second best thing
to do but when you got a beard you are
going to want
the finest in beard supplies okay it's
not just easy you wake up oh i woke up
like this this is how i look no
beard supply has the top selling
products beard oils soap
beard shears and beard bun it's a very
complicated thing my friend spencer
clavin goes on and on for hours
about all that is involved in keeping
his beard immaculate when you go to
beardsupply.com
use code knollscanner wlas on a
subscription product you'll get 50
off your first month not only does 50
off the first month sound great
but subscribing comes with its own perks
you get your product of choice
automatically delivered every one
two or three months it's your choice you
never worry about running out of it
again
you got to use code knowles can wles 50
off your first month of subscription
sign up right now so that you too can
start grooming
to get that beard the next best choice
if you can't play the ukulele
also ben's new book is coming out
ben's new book the authoritarian moment
is coming out
fairly soon it's great book to pre-order
right after you pre-order
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
which is available now for the next five
days on amazon and barnes noble and
elsewhere for pre-order
you can get ben's book also all those
same places any other major bookseller
a great thing about ben's book the
authoritarian moment is it doubles as my
future campaigns logan
knowles 2028 the authoritarian moment
also my friend georgia howe has a new
show
office hours it's available as a podcast
for uh from
all sorts of places that you get your
podcasts she'll be talking with
james lindsay to discuss critical race
theory should be talking
to abigail schreier about transgenderism
her show offers
a wealth of information from some of
america's most important voices
subscribe and download office hours with
georgia howe on apple podcasts or
whatever
your platform of choice may be we'll be
right back
the secretary of health and human
services refuse
refuses to call mothers mothers he only
calls them birthing people and speaking
of this
i have to address an issue that came up
i've gotten a lot of notes about this on
youtube and twitter and all sorts of
places
the rapper tom mcdonald put out a hit
song i mean this thing is
number one on the charts it's getting
zillions of views on youtube it's called
snowflakes and you know i'm not the most
hip-hoppy guy in the whole wide world
but it's uh it's an ironic sort of song
because it's in this
generally leftist medium of hip-hop but
it's very
uh right-wing in many of its talking
points talking about snowflakes you know
like the precious little snowflakes on
campuses
and i had a reaction to it we posted it
on youtube you can go check it out
but i i raised a question which was
the role of the woman you know these
these music videos tend to have
a woman or other women sort of dancing
around as the sex appeal
the woman in this video is played by a
man blair white
who i like blair white has been on this
show he's a guy who identifies as a
woman
and he's relatively right-wing about it
if such a thing can be true he
he doesn't believe he doesn't say that
he's a woman he knows that he's always
going to be a man but he just says it
makes him feel better to
have these cosmetic surgeries and and to
present himself as
a woman in the world and i said you know
i'm glad
that tom's music video is one of the
biggest songs
on the planet right now i'd rather
people be listening to this
more right-wing rap than to this
to most left-wing rap wap or something
like that by cardi b
i'm glad that if people are going to
watch a transvestite they're watching
blair white who has generally more
right-wing things to say
then who knows the drag queens will go
on nickelodeon i'm glad about that
but but
isn't there a risk here isn't there a
risk that in our zeal to own the libs we
are actually adopting their premises
this was always the fear of the caitlyn
jenner candidacy
yeah maybe caitlyn bruce jenner would be
a better
governor than gavin newsom maybe
maybe he would maybe he would have
better policies sort of
but the cost of that would be the
embrace of the radical gender ideology
is it and what i've been told by people
who defend blair's appearance in this
music video or who defend the caitlyn
jenner candidacy
is michael you don't get it it totally
owns the libs
because the libs you see they think that
they've got a lock on all the
transgender
people but actually some of them are
conservative
and so yeah it's going to totally own
the libs to
to what to embrace their
radical vision and rewriting of of human
nature itself
that's going to own the i think that's
owning ourselves
i think that's a price that's if we keep
owning the lives like that there aren't
going to be any conservatives left
well no michael you can be transgender
and conservative
not really you can have this issue of
gender dysphoria and be conservative
you can struggle with this issue where
you're a man but you either very much
desire to be a woman or you think that
you're a woman or whatever people have a
lot of quirks right
you can but if you are
totally embracing this i'm not quite
sure you can be very conservative and
it's a threat to the broader
conservative vision
there have been people there was a woman
who wrote into me
and uh a woman of a certain age who says
she was a 62 year old mother who said
michael this is outrageous i like you we
don't agree on everything but your video
about blair white was so childish the
whole point was that a beautiful
trans woman does not agree with
snowflakes and their pronoun crap but
but
she does she goes by she and you're
you're calling her a woman
so not only is is blair going along with
it to some degree
but even worse the viewers are going
along with it
blair white is not trying to take the
place of a woman she's just trying to
live her best life okay well even you
know blair is relatively quite grounded
on these issues
but you're referring to her but he is
not a she
the fear is forget even blair or bruce
jenner for a second
it's everybody else i know perfectly
conservative people who refer to caitlyn
jenner as she
or as caitlyn even i'm you know even i'm
doing it because it's very confusing
that's the fear that's the problem i
know that we all want to say yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes no we're the party of
yes to everything we're the biggest tent
in the world
well you know if the tent doesn't have
any tentpoles
anywhere if there are no limits no
demarcations then there is no such thing
as a conservative movement
just like if a nation doesn't have
borders it's not a nation a political
movement that has no boundaries
whatsoever
is not a political movement or it's a
completely impotent one like the
conservatives have been for decades at
this point
if we cannot at least put that tent pole
down and say
nature is human nature
that we can't totally remake human
nature if we can't even say that we
can't
say anything at all there's a lot of
pressure to give in
on the racial questions on the sexual
questions on the anti-american rights
all
the radical critical race theory there's
so much pressure to give in and say you
know what
white people are evil america's a white
supremacist country it's hopelessly
bigoted
on the sexual issues he has the
patriarchy it's really evil
head to rosis normative it's really evil
on the ante yes the founding fathers
were the worst people tear down the
statues there's so much pressure
you shouldn't give in ever people are
giving in them even marjorie taylor
green
who's a little kooky i think we can all
admit
i don't think there's anything wrong
about saying that she has said some
things that are a little out there okay
but she's also generally
stood up to the left in a way that is
not true of many other members of
congress marjorie taylor green got in
hot water because she compared
the current public health bureaucracy
and the draconian public health rules to
the holocaust to jews in nazi germany if
you have to show vaccine card it's
similar to wearing a
armband right yellow star on your on
your arm
now i don't really like holocaust
comparisons i just think they're clumsy
i think people make them generally
because they don't have other historical
perspective and so i just think they're
very tired
and i don't really make them myself
however the left just spent
not just four years the left has spent
40 years
comparing any republican that that in
any way threatens them to hitler calling
them all nazis they did it
they obviously did it to trump they
literally hitler they did it to george w
bush little hitler mustaches all the
time they did it to
ronald reagan they did it they've done
it to every republican
and yet only marge retailer green is
held accountable they forced her to go
to the holocaust museum and then to give
a little speech about all the things
she learned one of the best lessons that
my father always taught me
was when you make a mistake you should
own it
and i have made a mistake and it's
really bothered me for a couple of weeks
now
and so i definitely want to own it this
afternoon
i visited the holocaust museum the
horrors of the holocaust are something
that
some people don't even believe happened
and some people deny but there is no
comparison to the holocaust
and there are words that i have said
remarks that i've made
that i know are offensive and for that
i want to apologize she should not have
given the speech she should not have
apologized for this not because
i think you should make holocaust
comparisons i actually think people
should refrain from making holocaust
comparisons they're just
it's not not good rhetoric i don't think
it's particularly persuasive or
or pertinent but because
it's a it's a ridiculous double standard
nobody is actually offended
that marjorie taylor green made this
holocaust comparison
if they were then any of the leftists
who do this routinely who are still
doing this today
at every single level of the highest
levels of the democratic party down to
the lowest activists on the street they
all do it in the media they all do it
none of them ever has to go visit the
museum and give an apology
but marjorie green does big mistake big
mistake
you've got to recognize that in
political battles your opponents get a
say if you play by a completely
different set of rules a set of rules
that puts you at a distinct disadvantage
all the time if you have to apologize
for things that your opponents do not
have to apologize for
you are not in a good spot now marjorie
greene also at the same time
introduced the fire fouchy act
in the house of representatives one
imagines that perhaps
she had to go make this apology in order
to get the limelight for the fire fouchy
act
so this sort of the the way to redeem
oneself
uh marjorie green doesn't just want the
president to to fire vouchers she wants
to make this an act
of congress thank you for coming
everyone this is
this is an important issue that we need
to talk the american people
have endured terrible things over the
past year
due to the shutdowns from covid19
and i'm very proud to sponsor the
firefouche act and i'm grateful to
my colleagues here for co-sponsoring
this bill because the american people
deserve answers the firefouchee act
will bring dr fauci's salary down to
zero
and also will require the senate to
confirm
someone to fill his position
love it that's good stuff but michael
marjorie green says kooky things
sometimes yep sure
yep so does aoc so does ilhan omar so
does rashida talib so does
ayanna presley so does nancy pelosi so
does
maxine waters so does
oh gosh the list if you're talking about
democrats in congress the list goes on
and on and on and on are all of those
democratic members supposed to resign or
be booted out of
the house no you'll notice that all of
those women have said things that are
much
much worse and politically relevant than
whatever musings marjorie green has had
and the democrats always defend them
always and they use
those politicians when they can be
useful
so i think something like the firepouchy
act love it let's do it let's get behind
that
great great use of the legislative power
it's probably not going to get through
but it would be a great
great use of it but you know it's not dr
fatchi's fault nothing
nothing is ever dr fatchi's fault
you don't need to take my word for it
andy slavitt who is uh
joe biden's former kovidzar says that
the the failures and the difficulties of
the lockdowns it's not
because of fouchy it's not because of
the public health bureaucracy it's not
because of any of the politicians
it's just because you you deplorable
irredeemable bible thumping bitter
clinging american
just couldn't sacrifice a little bit
more of course we would have had a
pandemic here in the u.s no matter what
but
but look we can count the the mistakes
and i think it's important that we do
if for nothing else so we don't repeat
them we obviously had a set of technical
mistakes
with the testing and and the the ppe
that we know about
but if we're honest we also had two or
two other types of mistakes that caused
a lot of loss of life one were just
plainly political leadership mistakes
um there was a lot we denied the virus
for too long out of the trump white
house
we there was too much squashing of
dissent and playing on divisions
but i'd also think we all need to look
at one another and ask ourselves
what do we need to do better next time
and in many respects
being able to sacrifice a little bit for
one another um to get through this and
save more lives is going to be
it's going to be essential and that's
something that i think we could all have
done a little bit better on
yeah we all could have done a little bit
you know you just
yeah i know that we told you you'd you'd
shut down for 15 days and slow the
spread and i know we all told you not to
wear the masks and then we all and i
know that
we then extended the 15 days to over 15
months
and i know that we shuttered many many
of your businesses and we closed your
churches
and you didn't see your loved ones and
many of your loved ones died alone
for no reason at all for just complete
bs bunk
junk science and i know that we didn't
let your kids go to school for a year
and i know that you didn't get to have
your weddings and i know that you didn't
get your cancer treatment
because that was shut down for the far
more urgent cough
but you just should have sacrificed a
little couldn't you have sacrificed a
little more
that's the problem you know we we in the
public health bureaucracy we knew what
to do we had the right idea but you
you selfish slobs you just just
sacrifice a little bit more
so just a little bit more he says okay
okay
it's your fault it's not their fault
it's your fault
particularly when we say it's your fault
what is this
it gets back to the question at the top
of the show the nature of sin
in the current american understanding
everything
i don't think that slavit is referring
to the liberal people because the
liberal people they by definition did
what the scientists say because the
scientists are the liberal people so
they
that they're good but who needed to
sacrifice more it's really conservatives
if they were to choose a demographic
that is the source of all evil it's
obviously
straight white men we've we've heard
over the past week or two
the most clear examples of this that
psychiatrist at yale who said she has
fantasies of killing white men
the medical article published in a
peer-reviewed prominent medical journal
psychiatric journal
saying that whiteness is a terrible
disease that needs a permanent cure
you might say a final solution not to
make any comparisons
from what the words literally mean so
that's the specifically
the cause of all the evils but broadly
speaking they don't even just mean
straight white men
they mean any conservative who they mean
tim scott they mean
more certainly marjorie greene they mean
any
candace owens for sure who
espouses a conservative point of view
because in their idea
it gets right back to critical race
theory anyone who defends any sort of
conservative point of view is propping
up
white supremacy is propping up the
patriarchy
is laboring under a false consciousness
that is doing harm and injury
to other people just they're injuring
people if only
they had sacrificed more
never the fault of anybody else
why do we have forget the pandemic for a
second why do we have crime
we have crime because of this the white
supremacist
patriarchy which is why video just went
viral
there's a spate of of shoplifting going
on in san francisco there's a video of a
security guard watching
a guy not a straight white male
definitely a black guy
just with a giant bag filling up the bag
with stolen goods hopping on a bicycle
security guard is just filming and tries
to get the bag but the guy just
goes away and just rides right out of
the store there's not gonna be any
consequences
see ya see ya bye-bye
17 walgreens stores have had to close
uh according this according to the new
york times because the
scale of theft is so insane right now
because there are no consequences and
you know
in that guy's defense the the
shoplifters defense
he has been told by the entire
establishment
that it is his right to shoplift that he
is it's look it's wrong it's objectively
wrong it's a sin
to steal you're imperiling your your
soul
if you steal but he's not told that
according to our new religion with its
new liturgical calendar of
pride month in juneteenth according to
our new understanding of sin
which derives from racism instead of
sin itself it's not this guy's fault
he's the victim
society owes him whatever goods he's
i don't think he was stealing them for
personal use by the way he was just
shoveling them into a bag because he's
going to go sell them
this is not a this is not a starving man
stealing a loaf of bread
this guy certainly does not need to
steal but he's choosing to do it
and it's not entirely his i mean he
needs to take responsibility but it's
not entirely his fault because the whole
society is telling he has every right to
as the powers break down as society
breaks down
people need to take responsibility for
themselves i'm very pleased to see greg
abbott the governor of texas doing this
greg abbott is pointing out the federal
government is not going to build a
border wall they've stopped building the
border while they're they're
intentionally doing nothing on the
border joe biden when he ran for
president he said surge surge to the
border
the complete opposite of the trump
policy they're doing this of course
because it gives democrats an electoral
advantage so they want to flood the
country with people who are more likely
to
to vote for democrats either after an
amnesty or down the line
because of the modern notion of
birthright citizenship greg abbott says
you're not going to build the wall
we're going to build it ourselves by the
way i want to tell you something
for you to keep in mind later on this
week because when i do make the
announcement later on this week
i will also be providing uh a
a link that you can click on and go to
for everybody in the united states or in
real everybody in the entire world
who wants to help texas build a border
wall there will be a place on there
where they can contribute to
texas building the border wall oh that's
great and all proceeds go directly to
building that wall i assume
yeah so they they go to a fund in the
state of texas not a private entity not
an individual
but they will be overseen by the state
state of texas
in the governor's office great
transparency everyone will know
every penny in every penny out but the
sole purpose for those funds
will be going to build the border wall i
love it
i love it because there's nothing the
federal government can do here when
there have been private efforts to build
the border wall they've
ended up in accusations of fraud because
it's very very difficult to manage these
sorts of things
but this is in the state of texas the
federal government's going to probably
come in and tell them they can't do this
because the it's not that the federal
government through incompetence can't
seal the border it's through
an intentional effort they don't want
the border sealed they want the country
flooded with foreign nationals
love this from greg abbott great great
stuff president trump heading down to
the border
trump kamala won't go biden won't go
biden probably can't even leave the
house at this point he's got
he would miss matlock during the middle
of the day so donald trump is going to
go
he's going down at the invitation of of
governor abbott
this is a winning issue for republicans
the squishes always
always jump off on this they always
think that it's a
terrible idea it's going to lose voters
it won't it's a very popular idea it's
very popular
to seal up our border and restrict
immigration on the right it's even
popular in parts of the democratic party
federal government can't be bothered to
do that because they're too busy trying
to suppress
election audits we'll get into this a
little bit later later on in the week or
next week
but there is this audit going on in
arizona right now to oversee
the 2020 election to look at some of the
irregularities
let's say and now all of a sudden
merrick garland and the doj are really
concerned about this
they say that they're going to be
overseeing the audit they're going to
say
that there's they're already complaining
that some of the audit is utilizing
abnormal post-election methodologies
they weren't
concerned about the abnormal in some
cases unconstitutional methodologies
in states during the 2020 election but
now they're really concerned about the
audit i've never thought that the audit
would result in very much
as a political matter i do think that
there was obviously
uh some fraud and shenanigans in this
election there's fraud in every single
election it seems like in this one
that they took away in the months
proceeding basically all of the election
integrity measures
and the the excuse was covid but but i
suspect there was probably
more fraud than usual in the election i
don't think the audit's going to get
very much
the fact that garland is so concerned
about it is the first thing that tells
me huh that's a little weird
now i want now i really want to pay
attention in a way that i had not
not been paying all that much attention
before they're signaling a concern at
the federal
level here speaking speaking of that
election and federal accountability
ashley babbitt ashley babbitt was
the one person killed in the violence of
the the capital riot in january
she was killed she was a trump supporter
she was killed in the capital by
uh ostensibly capital police officer
ashley babbitt's husband is calling for
the name
of that cop mr roberts let me ask you
there have been reports
online that seem credible i don't know
if they're true that the capitol hill
police officer who shot
ashley babbitt i'm not going to mention
the name was the same officer who left
his
loaded handgun in a public men's room on
the capitol
do you believe that is the same officer
who seems like a very reckless person
who shot and killed ashley babbitt on
january 6th oh
that's that's my belief that's my belief
so if it turns out that she was shot for
reasons again they still haven't
explained to us
by a capitol hill police officer who
left a loaded handgun in a public men's
room and kept
his job somehow do you think maybe
that's why they're hiding his identity
um i don't know but i think one of the
reasons why they're hiding his identity
is they don't have a good explanation
for this shooting
now that the congress is voting to give
medals to the capitol police
who who kept down the riot that day we
all know
and they're trying to shame republicans
who don't do it we all know that if
ashley babbitt had been a blm rioter the
sorts of rioters who burned down
government and private buildings for
six months in 2020. if ashley babbitt
had been killed as a blm writer there
would be a federal investigation into
this
that cop's life would be absolutely we
would not know the name that cop's life
would be destroyed
the capitol police would not be getting
medals they would all be round up and
shipped to guantanamo bay
if many democrats had their way but but
that's
not what happened because ashley babbitt
was a conservative they're now
asking for no information to be given
out here and for everybody to go about
their merry way
and they want republicans to go along
with this it's a ridiculous double
standard it is not
what it seems to be about namely
honoring our police officers it's about
pushing a radical narrative
do not fall for it i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
speechless
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show